hello readers let's talk about structure
when architects and engineers design a
building one of the considerations they
have to make is structural support
how's this thing going to stay upright
how do we make sure it doesn't blow over
in the wind or collapse in an earthquake
and so they say okay maybe we'll put
reinforcing steel in the concrete or put
x braces on the outside or big old
pylons in the center well writers do
pretty much the same thing
when an author creates an informational
text they ask themselves the same
question how's this thing going to stay
upright how shall i structure this text
because although it's not physical in
the way that a building is physical
texts have structure
you can't touch them but you can see
them
now there are many ways to structure a
piece of writing but today i want to
talk about five
chronology compare and contrast cause
and effect problem in solution and
description
let's talk about each one in turn using
the medium of one of my favorite foods
pizza i recognize that's a really weird
looking pizza but uh you can learn
anything i'm going to get better at it
before this video is over
so chronology chronology is events
described in order chronos is greek for
time so anything that has that
distinctive c-h-r-o-n root is going to
be about time chronicle chronometer
chronically you can suss out if a text
is using a chronological structure if
it's a sequence in a particular order or
if it's telling a story from history
recipes are also chronological right in
order to bake the cake properly you have
to turn the oven on first and to that
end you can generally identify this text
structure by looking for time words like
first or last or finally so a
chronological account could be the
history of the origins of modern day
pizza in 19th century naples or a
step-by-step recipe for making pizza
dough
here's an example of the chronology of
ordering pizza
this is how you order pizza first look
up reviews or ask a neighbor to find the
best pizza near you then call the pizza
place and place your order be sure to
give your address
next it's time to wait
when the pizza finally arrives make sure
to tip the delivery person
compare and contrast you've probably
heard of this one when a text compares
two or more ideas that's a compare
contrast the compare step discusses
similarities how things are similar and
then the contrast step discusses how
those things are different
look for clue words like same or
different both and neither in contrast
or on the other hand
here's an example
when talking about pizza a long-standing
debate is often between deep dish and
thin crust pizza
one benefit of deep dish pizza is how
efficient it is because of its thickness
a 12 inch deep dish pie can serve six
people one drawback is that it can be
quite messy to eat
thin crust pizza is good because it's
less messy than deep dish but it's thin
so it takes a larger pizza or multiple
pizzas to feed the same number of people
as a deep dish pizza can
cause and effect this one does what it
says on the tin right it describes how
one idea or event causes another here's
an example to celebrate my great report
card my parents let me order pizza with
all my favorite toppings
after we ate we were too stuffed to do
anything else
now what caused us to get pizza my great
report card what was the effect of the
pizza we were stuffed maybe it was a
stuffed pizza if you stuff yourself with
stuffed pizza does that make you more
stuffed than if you stuff yourself with
unstuffed pizza you may scoff but this
is the stuff that keeps me up at night
problem and solution
in this kind of text structure the
author describes a problem and that
explains how that problem was solved so
imagine you want pizza but you can't
have traditional pizza because you're a
celiac you can't have wheat
necessity is the mother of invention
enter the cauliflower crust pizza made
from cooked cauliflower cheese and a
variety of gluten-free flours all right
so what was the problem you can't eat
wheat and pizza dough is made of wheat
how do you solve that problem by making
pizza crust out of cauliflower which i
promise tastes better than it sounds
finally description this is sort of like
an encyclopedia entry that explains
basic information about a topic like an
explainer piece about what pizza is
i'm going to read this as though i have
never heard of pizza before
pizza a round flatbread traditionally
served warm originated in naples italy
in the 19th century
this flatbread is generally baked at
very high temperatures topped with
flavorful tomato sauce and melted
mozzarella cheese and served in slices
if you find yourself looking at an
informational text and you're struggling
to figure out what the structure is
subtract the specifics if you subtract
the specifics it'll help you think about
the structure and if it helps you can
substitute those specific details about
the text with pizza
is this silly yeah of course does it
work i think it does
so is the text structured like a recipe
or the history of pizza if so it's
chronology is it comparing two kinds of
pizza well then it's a compare and
contrast does it explain how a good
report card led to a pizza dinner its
cause and effect
does it describe a pizza problem and how
it was solved in a pizza way well that's
a problem solution structure
and finally does it straightforwardly
describe what a pizza is without a
detailed chronology comparison or
problem because if so
that's a description
those are only five possible ways to
structure a piece of writing they're by
no means the only ways but identifying
these will give you the tools to learn
even more structures so that you can
better understand how writers shape
ideas
i hope that this helped and i also hope
that you want pizza now because i
certainly do
you can learn anything
dave it out